we've all heard the increasingly used
trendy term the Internet of Things and
how game-changing it's going to be as we
extend senses miniature sensors into
everyday objects everyday objects will
start to give us real-time feedback and
the world essentially will come along
this is the Internet of Things what if
we evolve the term a little further what
if instead of the Internet of Things we
enter the realm of the intelligence of
things the intelligence of things is
where the Internet of Things meets
artificial intelligence because the
future of artificial intelligence is
senseless unless we extend it into the
world of everyday objects this idea that
as we impregnate intelligence into the
world of physical things that we inhabit
the world essentially will come alive
this real-time feedback is interface
that will become in live
myth intelligence will essentially
create will birth a world that will
increasingly talk back to us now how
this will change human subjectivity how
this will change the human condition the
space of mine in which we dwell is in
the following way
increasingly will dovetail our minds to
the world right and as the world starts
talking back the distinction between
self and world will start to disappear
the external space the external world
will increasingly start to feel like an
extension of our mind like an extension
of our agency which will bleed over into
a world of predictability a world that
will know what we want before we want a
world of serendipity a world in which
you look for something you find
something else and analyze that what you
found was more conducive to your needs
and what you thought you were looking
for we're talking about a world
optimized for human creativity and human
enterprise a world that is responsive a
world that is alive a world that is
intelligent as I imagine so it becomes
and this is the very essence of magic
now
you're pumping all this data you're
pumping all this AI into sensors into
the world of ever
objects and again you birth the world
the intelligence of things the mind will
have fully turned itself inside out we
will be inhabiting the condensation of
human imagination the nodes in our brain
the neurons will have spilled out into
the world we will cloak the planet in
mind and data this my friends is a
singularity of mind and meaning when
everything becomes linked with
everything else matter becomes this is
the intelligence of States